Asalam alaikum.
My name is Ina. Uh I'm a farmer. Uh
>> you're a what farmer?
>> Yeah. Thank you for the opportunity. Uh
I want to ask about Islam teach us to
respect justice and other people
property.
But during the prophet's time uh taking
war booty raasan prang was allowed under
certain rules. How do we make sense of
that today? Does being in a state of war
really change the ethics of ownership?
>> She's she's saying if I can repeat the
question, her name is In. She's a farmer
and she says that Islam teaches us to
respect justice and uh the ownership of
property uh the rights of people over
property. However, during the time of
prophet, after the war, there was war
booty, property of people which was
snatched from the people. How that makes
sense today? Uh is that a contradiction
or can that be explained? I
>> just asked the question that we have to
respect people's property and land.
During the time of the prophet, they
used to snatch people's property. The
the word is wrong snatch.
It is normally it's called as ward
booty. In warb booty at the olden days
the rule was different. Now the rules
are different. Previously there was no
passport. Correct? Now this passport.
Previously the rule was who had a war
whoever won he was the owner. That was
the law that time. So in that time if a
war took place whoever wins he takes the
wealth he becomes the owner. That was
the law that time.
Now the law has changed.
So at that time the law was suppose
there's a battle if there is a war
whoever wins he becomes the owner
but even at the time of the prophet they
saw to it that they did not there were
some rules and regulation which I
discussed yesterday in yesterday's talk
I discussed that even in kal there are
some rules and regulation Allah says in
surah bakra chapter 2 verse number 290
that fight those who fight you but do
not commit transgression
while fighting. You cannot kill
children. You cannot kill women. You
cannot kill elderly people who are not
fighting you. You cannot kill the
animals of the people. You cannot chop
down trees. So you should understand the
difference between this. You cannot
break down monasteries, the places of
worship. That means there was some
unlike in other at that time they never
had these rules. They used to kill the
women. They used to kill the they used
to take the women and you know take them
away. Islam bought new rules. This war
bey is at the time of the war. But that
doesn't mean you can go and take
somebody else's gra. You cannot kill any
woman. You cannot kill any children.
Even if the enemy
elderly men you cannot touch unless they
come to in the battlefield to fight you.
That's a different question. You cannot
do something to cause a financial loss
to the enemy. You can't chop down trees.
But what you win in the battle that
becomes your property
means you're fighting you may get
horses, you may get whatever was a war
booty that is there that becomes your
property because that is and then from
that shared by people who are taking
part the battlefield. So that was the
law that looting was common which Islam
reduced it.
Now the laws are different. That time
the laws were different. Now the laws
are different. Today we have UNO that's
a different thing. They don't follow the
UN law.
They talk about UN law they are doing.
See now what's happening in Gaza.
More than 50,000 killed.
More than 15,000 children killed. Twoth3
of the people killed are women. They're
targeting civilian. They're targeting
hospitals that are all against
international law.
And no country is only talking. No one
is taking action.
Only talking.
The problem is today the Muslim Umah is
weak.
If we were united, this wouldn't have
happened.
Insh I'll be giving a talk on this
topic. 15point action plan for the
Muslim Ummah for the Palestinian cause
inshallah on 20th of July next Sunday in
Chakata inshallah. I hope the answer.
Thank you.